interesting I read an interesting study
that do you know who really are the
entrepreneurs statistically in the world
the C students yeah the C students
because they don't like to work in the
Box they don't follow rules they if
something is going to kind of be a waste
of time then they don't do it when
everybody else is kind of running by the
clock and the bell's gonna ring they
want to get the lesson done they want to
make sure they get their more interested
in grades where the entrepreneurs
looking outside the window dreaming his
dreams right he's thinking what am I
getting
um he's the one that that doesn't see
limitations he's the one that doesn't
want to be told what to do
um he can follow rules but he does he
but he wants to kind of chart his own
course